quarantänezeit ist natürlich die
allerbeste zeit um endlich mal alle
serien anzuschauen die man schon immer
mal schauen wollte und auch ein paar
neue zu liste hinzuzufügen
[Musik]
und dafür empfinde ich von ganzem herzen
lok ist blind auf netflix
das ist eine reality tv dating serie
und ja klar sie ist ein bisschen
stressig aber sie ist auch verdammt gute
träsch es geht darum dass sich 30
singles kennenlernen sollen ohne sich je
gesehen zu haben
sie denken sich in sogenannten potts das
sind so abgetrennte kleine kirchen und
wünschen sich aufgrund dieser gespräche
die sie dafür ein ineinander verlieben
müssen sie sich auch direkt verloren
erst dann können sie einander sehen die
serie thematisiert natürlich vor allem
die frage wie wichtig ist das äußerliche
bei partnern
sie thematisiert aber auch noch andere
gesellschaftliche fragen wie zum
beispiel chris dayton oder international
dating oder denken mit großem
altersunterschied und das macht sie so
spannend außerdem ist sie noch verdammt
gut produziert und sehr gut gecastet und
ich glaube sie passt einfach perfekt in
diese zeit denn wer weiß wenn die korona
krise noch weitergeht vielleicht denken
mir ja in den nächsten wochen alle
irgendwann in so kleinen stillen
kämmerchen mal schauen
ich empfehle euch wärmstens die serie
bleiben das weil sie einfach eine der
besten serien ist die ich in den
vergangenen jahren gesehen habe nicht
weil sie die spannendste geschichte hat
oder die überraschendsten wendungen
sondern weil sie einfach unfassbar
authentisch wirkt man muss sich
natürlich so ein bisschen für das
england der 1920 er jahre interessiert
und man muss auch ein bisschen spaß an
derben sprüchen
gewalt anja düsteren zeiten manchmal
abseits des gesetzes haben aber wenn man
sich diese serie anschaut dann erlebt
man nicht nur den grandiosen soundtrack
und sehr sehr sehr viele gerauchte
zigarette sondern auch einen
ausgezeichneten singen murphy in der
hauptrolle und einen nicht weniger guten
tom hardy als alfie solomons in der
nebenrolle
und ja die serie ist einfach perfekt um
so ein bisschen den kopf freizukriegen
von allem was einen so im alltag
beschäftigt
[Musik]
ich kann euch diese meint hunter sehr
empfehlen derzeit gibt es davon zwei
staffeln zu sehen also super für den
zeitvertreib
was mir persönlich an der see sind
gefallen hat sind zum einen die
entwicklungen der einzelnen charaktere
und zum anderen die handlung es geht die
mich um die anfänge der kriminologie
wovon man ja eigentlich eher weniger was
wird und es super spannend gemacht
die spannungskurve ist am anfang ein
bisschen flach aber es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall dran zu bleiben an diese alle
durch zuschauen
man lernt auch viel dabei und ist ein
super thema für krimifans auf jeden fall
wer es noch nicht kennt der sollte sich
in diesen tagen auf jeden fall leistet
development angucken was ich mal so die
mutter aller comedyserie nennen möchte
im kern geht es um die immobilien
unternehmer familie blues die von sehr
skurrilen charakteren gekennzeichnet ist
und durch niedriges geschäfts und
finanzgebaren in massive schwierigkeiten
geraten ist
die serie hat eine unheimlich hohe
dichte an pointen und unzählige running
gags und insgesamt ein sehr sehr subtil
teilweise ein bisschen versteckten humor
2013 und 18 sind nochmal eine vierte und
fünfte staffel von netflix dann
produziert worden
die erreichen zwar das niveau nicht mehr
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm weil die
ersten drei staffeln wirklich so gut
sind dass man sie sich immer wieder
anschauen kann und immer wieder neue
gäste noch mal entdeckt insofern das
perfekte programm also für quarantäne
zeiten und kostenlose corona
verhaltenstipps gibt sogar nach oben
drauf wir sehen noch nicht gesehen hat
dem würde ich ganz dringend die serie
sex and uk schnapp in den flex empfehlen
das klingt jetzt nach so einer
aufklärungs serie für kinder ist es aber
gar nicht
in der serie gibt es 16 jahre alter
schüler rotis seinen mitschülern und
auch lehrern 66 und die serie ist jungen
witzig gewaschen frech hat eine
unglaublich tolle musik und macht
einfach spaß zu gucken das wenig sie
jedem empfehlen würde
ich empfehle jedem der aktuellen nicht
genug angst hat in diesen besonderen tag
noch ein bisschen mehr stoff zum gruseln
hannibal ist eine tolle serie die lose
auf den roman von thomas harris basiert
richtig bekannt wurde stoff dann mit dem
filmen mit anthony hopkins also mehrere
filme schweigen der lämmer ist wohl der
bekannteste weil ich würde sagen die
serie ist noch ein bisschen besser was
nicht nur an mads mikkelsen seiner
diabolischen performance man sagt ja
immer dass solche geschichten total
realistisch sein sollen
tief in die psyche ihrer protagonisten
einkaufen sollen aber die serien
verweigert sich dem so ein bisschen und
ist eigentlich eher so eine riesige die
ästhetik der gewalt wir erwischen
eigentlich niemanden direkt beim töten
in flagranti wir wissen auch nicht warum
irgendjemand tötet stattdessen bekommen
wir als zuschauer einfach leichen
präsentiert die wie schaurige stillleben
wie kunstwerke eigentlich ausgestellt
sind die mörder sind also sozusagen
künstler die sich in so einem perversen
überbietungswettbewerb und als
identifikationsfigur für den zuschauer
haben wir einen profiler der sich
buchstäblich in die mörder
hineinversetzen kann und dabei selbst
natürlich immer mehr dem wahnsinn
verfällt und der schauspieler hugh dancy
macht es mit sensationellem theater
overacting was man sich eigentlich nicht
oft genug anschauen kann vor allem wenn
man nun freiwillig mehrere wochen zu
hause festsitzt ich empfehle die serie
die laster was von tomb raider und damon
lindelof geschrieben wenn du noch
verdanken so tolle sachen lost oder neue
watchmen serie und in die letzte war
schaute sich an was passiert wenn zwei
prozent der weltbevölkerung von heute
auf morgen plötzlich verschwinden
mysteriöserweise ist momentan so
sehenswert weil sie eben zeigt was das
mit menschen macht wenn sie in einer
extremsituation kommen wie sie irgendwie
probieren damit umzugehen
für welche sachen sie sich entscheiden
ob sie sich lieber in einer gesellschaft
hinein begeben wollen
tolles und miteinander funktioniert oder
ob sie und wie gegeneinander arbeiten
und zum scheitern verurteilt sind
sehr sehenswert sehr anspruchsvoll war
mal ein bisschen mit dem zeit- ebenen
arbeiten muss so wie auch schon bei lost
wo man ja manchmal nicht wusste ist dass
jetzt vorher oder nachher ein bisschen
zurückspulen muss manchmal um das
wirklich alles nachvollziehen zu können
aber das kann man ja dank streaming
heutzutage
wer zu hause nichts zu tun hat dem würde
ich die serie hunters empfehlen und
irgendwie schlag mich tot erinnert mich
dieser serie extrem stark an filme von
quentin tarantino kill bill
unglaublich bastards vielleicht hat es
auch mit der farbgebung im film zu tun
allgemein geht es einfach nur darum dass
ein junger sich seine nazi jäger gruppe
anschließt und nazis die nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg in nach in die usa
geflohen sind bedingungslos jagd und das
ist der ganze plot im endeffekt einfach
und unterhaltsam
1 0 für kloten